il est 13 heures 4 ce lundi 11 mai 87
klaus barbie l'ancien chef de la gestapo
de lyon pénètre dans le prétoire plus de
quarante ans après la guerre il répondra
une cour d'assises de crimes contre
l'humanité c'est la première fois que
l'on poursuit quelqu'un sous ce chef la
notion même de crimes contre l'humanité
est encore flou est sujette à
controverse procès ordinaire sur le plan
pénal extraordinaire par la qualité de
l'accusé et les passions qu'il réveille
présente dès le premier jour la
communauté juive de lyon n'a pas oublié
les milliers de déportés sous le règne
de klaus barbie je n'ai pas l'impression
qu'il ya le moindre remords le moindre
prêt à mentir vis-à-vis des crimes qu'il
a pu commettre on peut pas s'empêcher
d'être content satisfait que cet homme
là se trouveraient dans la boxe accusés
à lyon
harbi ne restera pas longtemps dans son
box deux jours seulement après
l'ouverture des débats s'il tire sa
révérence
mais faisable
[Musique]
je suis ici de façon illégale j'ai été
victime d'un enlèvement et je n'ai pas
l'intention de reparaître devant ce
tribunal se sont provisoirement ses
derniers mots malgré l'absence de barbie
le procès continue ses victimes révèlent
ce qu'elles ont subi une horreur à
laquelle personne ne s'attendait leurs
témoignages font monter les débats d'un
cran à aucun moment on ne retrouvera une
qu'à l'émotion
j'ai dit à mes parents il ya meilleur
que mon frère n'est plus de ce monde
[Musique]
j'ai eu deux mois
nous avons fait la preuve je ressent
effectivement je suis une miraculée
barbie a prétendu qu'il était d'abord un
soldat moi je prétends qu'un soldat fait
la guerre et je prétends que aucun des
orphelins 18e ne présentait un intérêt
militaire quelconque pour le troisième
âge est une bête sauvage vous savez on
peut pas appeler ça un homme
ce qui est tellement extraordinaire chez
bar me kiffe unis une douche est
beaucoup c'est cette joie satanique qui
l'avaient torturé avec il éprouvait
vraiment une jouissance extrême
lui si on criait alors il il rayonnait
il est avait réussi à vous arracher un
tri savez la promesse qu'on a fait un
autre à ceux qui mouraient
alain schmitz ceux qui partaient au
crématoire
[Musique]
tu es de témoins jusqu'au bout
joli vrai je témoignerai le 26 mai pour
la première fois barbie est amené à
comparaître par la force pour être
confronté aux témoins qui n'ont pas vu
pendant l'instruction tous le reconnaît
formellement
des témoignages accablants
il savait très bien où nous envoyez donc
c'est moi c'est tout ce que j'ai à lui
reprocher qu'est-ce qu'il est toujours
proche des autres je trouve que sa suite
il y marquer
de quoi mieux
[Musique]
je crois que tout le monde leur héros
sarsgaard
parce que je suis médecin que j'avais
fait de la médecine légale que je sais
reconnaître une oreille je sais
reconnaître diverses choses et je les ai
noté en disant toi mon gars tu peux te
faire lifter comme tu voudras sur quoi
l'attrait toujours
harvey qui quitte le palais par une
entrée dérobée et jacques chaban delmas
qui va entrer par la grande porte tout
un symbole le triomphe de la résistance
les soi disant révélations de jacques
vergès ont fait long feu
ce procès je voulais 10 est un procès d'
utile
utile pour ce que je vous ai dit
c'est la vérité
et puis la méditation sur la vérité
la vigilance pour l'avenir
pour le retour de la barbarie y aura 6
fanta barbie
son sort est scellé de toute manière
barbie est un criminel nazi non repentis
et c'est pour ça qu'il est jugé mais au
delà de la personnalité de barbie il est
aussi le produit du régime nazi et c'est
ça qui me paraît important place des
terreaux la communauté juive a érigé le
temps du procès un mémorial de
l'holocauste avant de témoigner elie
wiesel prix nobel de la paix et rescapé
d'auschwitz est venu se recueillir
je ne crois pas à la vengeance
mais je crois à la justice
je crois à la justice dans le cadre de
la mémoire
je sais sans mémoire ne passe
aujourd'hui
est ensuite les plaidoiries des parties
civiles difficile pour elle de trouver
des arguments plus forts que ceux des
témoins certains seront malgré tout
trouver les mots justes ce procès est il
à la fois pour nos contemporains à la
fois aussi pour ceux qui dans quelques
années dans quelques dizaines d'années
auront à se rappeler ce qu'a été
l'occupation ces atrocités ce sont des
crimes qui sont imprescriptibles par
nature nous devons bien le comprendre je
les tenter de l'expliquer aux jurés je
suis certain qu'ils m'ont bien écouter
la notion de crime contre l'humanité
n'est pas encore complètement comprise
par tout le monde qu'il faut qu'elle
soit mieux comprise que c'est un crime
supranationale un crime donc l'ensemble
des nations civilisées son responsable
responsable de sa répression en vue
autant de preuves accumulées sur un seul
homme présumé coupable c'est vraiment vu
le dixième de ses pôles suffit à faire
condamner n'importe qui ouvre la saison
exténué pierre truche procureur général
après un réquisitoire de deux jours sous
une chaleur torride et ne reconnaît
aucune circonstance atténuante à barbie
ont d'ailleurs eu égard aux victimes il
se refuse même le droit de pouvoir les
impôts
plainte à ce qu il a dit serge klarsfeld
à la new york
pas me dire ça
les anciens ont réclamé la prison à
perpétuité
[Musique]
vidic rooney plaie de relativement un
quadricycle war du booker truche jette
dans le même état d'esprit tout à fait
toujours confiant
deux jours
les trois défenseurs de klaus barbie
jacques vergès a été égal à lui-même
talentueux mais aussi parfois outrancier
provocateur tout comme l'algérien nabil
whittall s'est comporté plus un
idéologue que en véritable avocat qui en
même au passage d'incidents finalement
la surprise est venue de mettre même bas
alors en quoi ce procédé est
significative mais je les dis simplement
parce que j'estime que ça la
participation des gens d'autres
continents peut-être que beaucoup ne
seraient jamais qui s'est passé des
choses affreuses à madagascar ou pour
vos séances le moment plus que jamais
demandé de mettre tout cela sur
sur une table non pas pour chercher
vengeance pour demander des prochaines
voulons simplement pour avoir une vue
complète afin de dégager définition sur
le crime contre l'humanité qui puisse
pas faire un peu loin que de racisme
hier soir après plus de six heures de
délibéré les jurés ont rejeté tous les
arguments de la défense répondant oui à
toutes les questions sur la culpabilité
non sur les circonstances atténuantes
verdict réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité
[Musique]